Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
kembly tu plataforma de aprendizaje
online de inglés con tutores nativos os
contamos más detalles en un
[Música]
momento si hablamos de música hay un
estilo que últimamente destaca por
encima de todos los demás y no no nos
referimos al último éxito de Taylor
Swift sino a los tambores de guerra la
ofensiva en la franja de gaza el
agotador conflicto en Ucrania las
múltiples guerras civiles africanas por
aquí y por allá las escaramuzas de los
hutíes en el mar rojo y también los
vientos belicistas que de repente y de
forma totalmente inesperada se han
desatado en pleno mar Caribe El Comando
sur de Estados Unidos inicia ejercicios
militares en Guyana en medio de las
tensiones con Venezuela maduro ordena
una acción conjunta defensiva en
respuesta al envío de un barco de guerra
británico a Guyana pese a las promesas
de no agresión maduro volvió a amenazar
a Guyana por el reclamo sobre el
esequivo en diciembre del 2023 el
patrullero Trend de la armada británica
llegó al mar Caribe para realizar tareas
relacionadas con la lucha contra el
contrabando y el tráfico humano
sustituye a su buque gemelo el medway
que estará un tiempo en mantenimiento en
El Astillero de Gibraltar Sin embargo a
finales de mes el Trend fue desviado con
el objetivo de atravesar las aguas de
Guyana en el marco de sus patrullas lo
que encendió la ira de Caracas como ya
sabéis la revolución bolivariana está en
plena Cruzada nacionalista con
Georgetown por la disputa territorial
que Guyana y Venezuela mantienen por el
esequivo algo de lo que ya os hablamos
hace poco aquí en visual politic la
respuesta chavista Pues un despliegue
que involucró cerca de 5000 efectivos
militares así como docenas de navíos y
aeronaves militares en el Caribe
Oriental venezolano una acción conjunta
de carácter defensiva como respuesta a
la provocación y a la amenaza del Reino
Unido contra la paz y la soberanía de
nuestro país
a pesar de que el hms Trend ya abandonó
las aguas en disputa los ejercicios y
las constantes amenazas felicistas están
comenzando a hacer mucho ruido y aunque
un conflicto nos parece hoy por hoy
completamente inverosímil Aunque visto
lo visto últimamente vete tú a saber
esto ha hecho que en visual politic nos
hagamos unas cuantas preguntas Cómo de
fuerte es la capacidad militar de
Venezuela podrían las fuerzas armadas
bolivarianas sostener realmente un
esfuerzo de Invasión y guerra chispa hay
realmente en el brazo armado de la
Revolución bolivariana y qué papel
juegan las ingentes compras de armas
rusas y chinas que el régimen chavista
ha hecho en las últimas dos décadas pues
amigos amigas todo esto y más lo vamos a
ver a continuación gasolina y
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
dejadme que os pregunte algo no os ha
pasado que vais por ejemplo de viaje o
tenéis que hablar con alguien en el
trabajo que solo habla inglés y sentís
cierta inseguridad a ver no tenemos que
engañarnos a todos de una forma u otra
nos ha pasado alguna vez pues veréis una
de las razones por las que surge esa
inseguridad a la hora de hablar inglés
es por la falta de práctica por no estar
habituado a hablar con gente nativa Pues
bien para solucionar Esto está kembly
kembly es una plataforma de aprendizaje
de inglés online desde vuestra propia
casa estés en el país que estés podréis
hablar con tutores nativos de varias
partes del mundo y con distintos acentos
Para Olvidar de una vez por todas
vuestros problemas con el inglés y
sabéis que es lo mejor podéis hacerlo
las 24 horas del día y elegir entre
sesiones particulares o grupales
adaptadas a tu nivel chulo no os parece
Pues bien muy atentos a esto Ahora solo
por estar viendo Este vídeo kembly
ofrece un descuentazo del 56 por
utilizando el cupón visual kembly 2024
por menos de
10,99 al mes o 219 pes mexicanos tendrás
30 minutos a la semana de clase con
nativos nos parece una ofertaza Pues si
queres quitarle el óxido a vuestro nivel
de inglés y sorprender a vuestros amigos
y compañeros de trabajo tenéis el link
disponible aquí debajo en el comentario
fijado y en la descripción también
podéis utilizar este QR que aparece en
pantalla la oferta es solo válida por 72
horas y ahora sí continuemos con el
poder militar de la Venezuela
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bolivariana
puede que os sorprenda pero lo cierto Es
que la capacidad militar de Venezuela
siempre ha sido por diferentes motivos
un tema caliente en las Américas fijaos
en lo que se comentaba ya en los años 50
Venezuela depende de fuentes extranjeras
para Prácticamente todo su material
militar Y aunque existe una preferencia
por los equipos estadounidenses sobre
todo los más pesados los jefes militares
venezolanos están irritados porque
Estados Unidos no les vende los últimos
modelos de los mejores equipos Así que
cuando Washington a partir de los años
60 quiso prevenir la infiltración
soviética en la región para evitar otra
Revolución al estilo de la de Cuba
Venezuela se convirtió durante décadas
en el niño bueno del Team latam primero
porque era una democracia segundo porque
era un país relativamente rico en
relación con sus vecinos y tercero
porque era un importante socio
energético Así que en cierto modo
Estados Unidos pensó qué podría hacer de
Venezuela una punta de lanza contra la
influencia soviética en el mar Caribe y
de hecho por ejemplo durante la crisis
de los misiles de Cuba dos Destructores
venezolanos el nueva Esparta y el zulia
participaron en el bloqueo de la isla de
Cuba de esta forma poco a poco
Washington contribuyó a modernizar las
fuerzas armadas de Venezuela por ejemplo
permitiéndoles la adquisición en
1983 de 24 aviones de combate f16 por
aquel entonces uno de los más modernos
del mercado sí hace cuatro décadas
Venezuela ya tenía acceso al mismo tipo
de avión que ahora puede llegar a
Ucrania por aquella época Venezuela
también adquirió fragatas de la clase
lupo que por aquel entonces estaban a la
vanguardia en materia de poder de fuego
en
alamar son solo dos ejemplos el dinero
del petróleo y las buenas relaciones con
occidente estaban permitiendo que
Venezuela estuviera poco a poco
desarrollando unas fuerzas armadas
pequeñas razonablemente modernas y
funcionales para qué pues para controlar
el Caribe y también a su vecina Colombia
por ejemplo el 9 de agosto de 1987 se
produjo un incidente que a punto estuvo
de irse de las manos una corbeta
colombiana la caldas entró en aguas
venezolanas reclamadas por Colombia en
base a la última posición que tengo de
usted sobre la carta le reitero mi
invitación a retirarse de aguas
territoriales
venezolanas repito le reitero mi
invitación a retirarse de las aguas
territoriales de la República de
Venezuela la negativa del buque
colombiano terminó con los flamantes f16
nuevos preparados para atacar y con un
ultimatum de Venezuela que al final
Bogotá aceptó Claro que toda esta
apuesta venezolana cambió por completo
con la llegada de Hugo Chávez al poder
en 1998 ahí comenzó a ponerse en marcha
el nuevo ejército bolivariano
atentos
una modernización
colorada queridos amigos y amigas Pese a
que en sus discursos a veces se
convertía en un personaje pintoresco
Hugo Rafael Chávez frías era ante todo
un
militar en 2008 Chávez impulsó una
reforma de los reglamentos militares
para poder ser un miembro activo de las
fuerzas armadas Bajo su condición
constitucional de comandante en jefe lo
que por ejemplo lo habilitaba utizar su
uniforme de campaña en actos oficiales
la vinculación del Comandante con las
fuerzas armadas era intensa y ya en 2004
la modernización de las fuerzas armadas
se convirtió en toda una prioridad para
su gobierno de esta forma el chavismo
lanzó hacia el año 2005 una línea
estratégica conocida como el
fortalecimiento del poder militar esta
apuesta consistía en un ambicioso plan
de reequipamiento militar Revolución
nuestra hay que recordarlo
pacífica pero Armada se equivoquen
burgueses lo que no les vamos a permitir
es que incendi nuestro país tengan la
seguridad que no y no hablo solo por el
gobierno hablo por el pueblo los
trabajadores los civiles y los
militares Claro que algunas cosas ya
estaban cambiando Bush prohíbe la venta
de armas a Chávez Janel hironimus
portavoz del departamento de estado dijo
que Venezuela había forjado estrechas
relaciones con Irán y Cuba ambos
clasificados por Estados Unidos como
estados patrocinadores del terrorismo
esta medida tomada por la Casa Blanca
bca fue un duro golpe para las fuerzas
armadas venezolanas que como ya os hemos
comentado tanto en lo que se refiere a
los equipos como a los suministros
militares las doctrinas de defensa o las
capacidades de gestión y mantenimiento
estaban construidas en torno al equipo
militar occidental claro que el
comandante lo que vio fue toda una
oportunidad el momento perfecto para
acabar precisamente con esa vinculación
occidental Así que lo que hizo fue tirar
de la chequera para firmar millonarios
contratos armamentísticos con sus dos
nuevos socios precedentes Rusia y
China tal y como podéis ver en este
gráfico la modernización de las fuerzas
armadas venezolanas se dio en dos tamos
Una entre 2006 y 2009 y otra entre los
años 2011 y 2013 en conjunto Las
importaciones de armamento fueron
desproporcionadamente más grandes que
los años anteriores y principalmente
dependían de pedidos a Rusia y China de
esta forma si bien Caracas mantuvo
pedidos a la industria militar de países
como Holanda Austria y España para el
suministro de aviones ligeros de
vigilancia o lanchas de patrullaje
marítimo El grueso de la relación tuvo
que ver con sus nuevos Socios con china
por ejemplo se firmaron multimillonarios
contratos para la compra de uniforme
chalecos aviones de entrenamiento
munición de artillería helicópteros
antisubmarinos o vehículos antimotines
como es el caso del norinco vn4 y el
norinco ab1 por su parte a Moscú con
mucha diferencia su mayor proveedor se
le encargó el suministro de sistemas de
misiles de defensas antiaéreas
helicópteros de combate y más de 100
tanques de72
modernizados con todo el juguete
preferido de los militares venezolanos
en este periodo fue sin duda alguna el
suji 30 mk2 el nuevo guardián de los
cielos de la
Revolución y es que veréis el f16 tiene
sin duda muchas ventajas pero con 20
años a sus espaldas y sobre todo sin
ayuda norteamericana para su
mantenimiento y actualización seguir
contando con ellos era casi imposible
posible Así que el gobierno venezolano
se aseguró de recibir 24 de estos
aviones y de esta forma durante la
primera década del siglo 21 Venezuela
logró dar un importante paso hacia
delante en materia militar hay que
decirlo Chávez las ingenió para mantener
la ventaja comparativa que Caracas tenía
con sus vecinos lo que condujo por
cierto a Washington a considerar que
sería recomendable cerrar esa brecha
Rusia se ha convertido en el principal
exportador de armas del gobierno de
Chávez entre las compras recientes
figuran sistemas rusos de defensa
antiaérea helicópteros y cazas o yuz 30
Venezuela recurre a Rusia por equilibrio
geoestratégico y en ocasiones por
necesidad pragmática tras el embargo de
armas impuesto por Estados Unidos en
2006 si Venezuela sigue buscando
contratos de armas con Rusia es
concebible que Estados Unidos aumente su
ayuda militar a Colombia para preservar
la ventaja militar colombiana Colombia
se encuentra en desventaja estratégica
ante la flota de superioridad aérea más
representativa de la región que cuenta
con los su3 mk2 rusos o cazabombarderos
sukoi propiedad de Venezuela y así la
revolución bolivariana quedó bastante
bien Armada Claro que luego llegó la
crisis y las compras se frenaron en Seco
como diría Miley no hay plata Eso sí los
juguetes que se habían comprado estaban
disponibles y la revolución no tardó en
echarles mano ojo que esto quizás os va
a
[Música]
sorprender Colombia El eterno chivo
expiatorio Colombia Venezuela son países
hermanos lucharon juntas en la guerra de
Independencia y además fueron un único
país la gran Colombia entre 1819 y 1830
pese a ello a lo largo de los años han
tenido todo tipo de tiras y aflojas como
ya hemos visto en los años 80 Caracas y
Bogotá estuvieron a punto de acabar en
guerra fue un conflicto esencialmente
territorial en los últimos años sin
embargo las cosas se pusieron aún más
complicadas Y es que veréis en el año
2008 el gobierno de Colombia bajo lgo de
Álvaro Uribe y con Juan Manuel Santos
como ministro de defensa ordenó la
operación Fénix esta operación consistió
en un ataque militar a una base de las
fark radicada en territorio ecuatoriano
estao así una crisis que rápidamente
escaló a escala regional sobre todo
cuando Hugo Chávez entró en escena esto
puede ser el comienzo de una guerra en
Suramérica Porque si por ejemplo usted
se le ocurre hacer eso en Venezuela
presidente Uribe le mando uno suco
compañero para que lo sepa señor
ministro de defensa muévame 10
batallones hacia la frontera con
Colombia de inmediato batallones de
tanques la Aviación militar que se
despliegue nosotros no queremos guerra
pero no le vamos a permitir al imperio
norteamericano que es el amo y a su
cachorro el presidente Uribe y la
oligarquía colombiana que nos vengan a
dividir que nos vengan a
debilitar la cuestión es que el gobierno
colombiano estaba anunciando la
presencia de las fark en territorio
venezolano y sus vínculos en ciertos
sectores militares venezolanos para
colmo ira de Caracas el presidente
colombiano Álvaro Uribe firmó un acuerdo
con el presidente Barack Obama para
concretar el uso de siete bases
militares conjuntas para luchar contra
el narcotráfico y el terrorismo algo que
Chávez vio como una especie de amenaza
que no se le ocurra A la oligarquía
colombiana porque se estarían metiendo
con los soldados de Bolívar y con el
pueblo de Bolívar pronto vamos a
comenzar a disparar los suy Yo quiero ir
en el primer disparo a 200 km llega el
misil del
sukoi y ojo porque el propio bribe ha
reconocido que los ataques a territorio
venezolano eran una posibilidad bastante
real Yo tenía tres opciones quedarme
callado hoy sería difícil presentarme
ante ustedes qué tal que yo me hubiera
quedado callado la otra opción era un
operativo militar en Venezuela Me faltó
tiempo me faltó tiempo Claro que la cosa
no fue mayores poco a poco el tema se
fue calmando siempre quedará el
interrogante de si Hugo Chávez realmente
habría estado dispuesto a emplear su
nuevo Arsenal ruso chino en una guerra
abierta contra Colombia sea como sea la
movilización militar venezolana entre
los años 2008 y 2010 fue Útil para que
sus fuerzas armadas se prepararan
digamos que se aceleraron las prácticas
de vuelo ejercicios de batalla los
simulacros de tiro y todo tipo de
maniobras con el nuevo equipamiento
comprado a rusos y chinos en otras
palabras que Chávez utilizó la hipótesis
de la guerra para acelerar la
preparación del ejército venezolano Y
aunque todavía no se han probado esas
capacidades parece Sensato suponer que
la compra de Nuevo armamento mejoró pese
al desastre que es la revolución las
capacidades militares de Venezuela pero
están realmente preparadas para una
posible invasión de Guyana pues
[Música]
atentos perro ladrador poco
mordedor según el ranking de global fire
Power Venezuela ocupa el puesto 52 en
cuanto a poder de fuego las fuerzas
armadas venezolanas tienen 130,000
efectivos y cuentan con 250 aeronaves de
las cuales 44 son de ataque y 46
embarcaciones de guerra no son unas
fuerzas armadas particularmente grandes
Pero serían suficientes para hacerse con
el esquivo pensad que desde que dio
comienzo la revolución bolivariana ha
pasado Ya casi un cuarto de siglo más de
20 años de corruptelas amiguismo
enchufismo de todo tipo para colmo la
crisis de los últimos años ha hecho que
se desplome el gasto militar lo que por
supuesto tiene consecuencias en términos
de mantenimiento entrenamiento y
operatividad pues bien fijaos como a
partir de 2014 se desploma el gasto
militar aviones de combate sukoi de
Venezuela tendrían menos horas de vuelo
que el promedio a esta situación le
tenemos que Añadir el hecho de que gran
parte de los equipos rusos que hoy
forman el corazón militar de Venezuela
han demostrado importantes deficiencias
operativas en el frente ucraniano Por lo
que existen múltiples dudas respecto a
su capacidad real de combate por si
fuese poco en los últimos años los
militares venezolanos han asumido Muchas
tareas civiles especialmente las
relacionadas con el funcionamiento de
las empresas públicas y los negocios
petroleros es decir que poco a poco han
ido transformando sus prioridades hasta
el punto de que el rol del oficial
técnico es decir el efectivo militar
profesional enfocado en los niveles
tácticos está casi extinto y eso no es
todo
Además desde la modernización venezolana
sus vecinos Colombia y sobre todo Brasil
han hecho grandes avances en lo que se
refiere a sus capacidades militares y no
olvidemos que Brasil ya ha venido a
decir que acudiría en apoyo de Guyana En
otras palabras teóricamente sobre la
mesa el ejército venezolano tiene la
capacidad de invadir Guyana y recuperar
el esequivo Al fin y al cabo los 130,000
efectivos militares con los que cuenta
Caracas equivalen al 16 de toda la
población de Guyana pero en realidad
queridos amigos ha llovido mucho desde
los mejores días de la capacidad militar
bolivariana lo más probable es que
Guyana recibiese asistencia militar de
Brasil y Estados Unidos y por pequeña
que fuese Venezuela no parece hoy un
actor capaz de resistir En otras
palabras quizás nos equivoquemos pero no
creemos que esa invasión sea hoy por hoy
algo factible lo más probable es que el
ejército venezolano se disolverse como
un azucarillo sea como sea esperemos que
no tengamos que comprobarlo dicho esto
la pregunta es qué opinas de las
capacidades militares venezolanas crees
que siguen estando a la altura Cómo
crees que se desempeñaría este país en
caso de conflicto déjanos como siempre
tus impresiones en los comentarios y si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle al botón de like Échale
también un vistazo a la promoción tan
interesante de kembly un 56 de descuento
con el código visual kembly 2024 Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la
[Música]
próxima i